ah yes
this is great though right here
twist is a ventriloquist now
the rapper
what up y'all it's your boy twister and
this is the most
ah thing I've ever seen in my [ __ ]
life dude you know how fast he rapped he
was just like
but sentences dude Twista would just be
like
but saying sentences that fast and now
dude first of all he's got a [ __ ]
ventriloquist with a backwards hat on
and a shirt that I would wear from
American Apparel in [ __ ] 2006. and
Twista is sitting there dude and this is
hey hey it's a little twisty you did
yeah yeah
dude ventriloquism
sucks
hey it's 2022. we're done with that like
we're done with mimes
you know why there are video games that
you can just literally insert yourself
in
hey ventriloquism we're past that
hey Twista weird Hobby
hey hey what's up I could do it dude you
know
I feel like honestly if I tried hard for
a day I could be one of the best
ventriloquists in the world
hey hey what's up hey I'm little Chris
Chris I'm little Chris what's going on
what what the [ __ ]
hey what the [ __ ] somebody left the door
open
hey Chris hey hey dick Chris get your
hand out of my anus
that that's where it is you know yeah I
I know little I know little Chris
hey hey
just [ __ ] drinking with it
God how stupid
that was a live introduction
and you know it
do it yourself you don't need the
[ __ ] that's impressive on its own
dude he's making all those noises with
his [ __ ] mouth and then all he's
doing is this
anyway I don't even know what this
puppet is [ __ ] saying you know
dude twister yeah
oh really yeah
dude I gotta have a [ __ ]
ventriloquist act for real like I I'm
talking about go in do two nights do one
is my comedy [ __ ] and the next one is
crystalia and Lil Chris
ventriloquism at its finest and then the
next night I still think it's for my
ventriloquist act and I don't even
practice
[Laughter]
I bring little Chris out I what do you
mean what oh [ __ ] I guess he came
prematurely you got the
ah [ __ ]
stop roasting me
oh God damn man just not practicing
buddy
dude my dad saw this little twisted
doing ventriloquism he wouldn't
understand what was happening
and he's pretty with it you know for a
74 year old
my dad would just be like who's that and
what is that saying and also the guy
what is he saying
and I'd he'd say twister and I'd be like
no like yeah but it's Twista oh okay and
he's a singer that's what he would
that's what the whole conversation would
be I'd be like he's a rapper oh okay
who does he rap with he did a big song
with Jamie Foxx the actor gets
never mind
twister and then you'd walk away
often tall
wow that's I mean what the [ __ ] dude
what up y'all it's your boy twister and
uh
it's
listening
dude
do you know just
hey hey a little twisting you dick he's
trying so hard not to move like trying
so hard not to move that it's making it
like it's weirdly still like you nobody
when the dude it's so funny
ventriloquist when the puppet's talking
there like this
[Laughter]
dude hey what's going on little twister
is everything good
yes that's fine
we're all good you know yeah so anyway
wow dude
and I make you a celebrity overnight
and I'm making myself a little bit
overnight
and I make you a celebrity overnight
[Music]
um
hello
[Music]
[Music]